it's been 10 years since 20 children and
six adults were killed at Sandy Hook
Elementary School in recognition of that
we're bringing you the latest
installment of our series note to self
Isaiah Marquez green now 18 years old
was that Sandy Hook that day he survived
the shooting but his younger sister Anna
Grace was killed in this note he wrote
to his younger self he reflects on what
happened that day and his sister's
Legacy
dear Isaiah you're eight years old
you're the light in the eyes of your
mother your father and your sister you
weren't born into a rich family but you
have a rich family history
you are a proud descendant of enslaved
people
your parents teach you so much about
your Puerto Rican and black heritage
you are surrounded by family and friends
in Canada Puerto Rico and the United
States
and I look at you Isaiah I see a smart
funny young kid who loves hockey Star
Wars sharks Legos and most of all God
hold on to the lessons you learn from
him you will desperately need them
you have been living in Winnipeg
Manitoba for three years your father got
an exciting job there as a music
professor but in the summer of 2012 you
will leave Winnipeg and move back home
to Connecticut
on a cold morning just weeks before
Christmas your six-year-old sister Anna
your best friend will be killed at the
Sandy Hook school shooting
a day of unimaginable horror here you
Isaiah will somehow escape the building
but once out you will all need a lot of
help
your friends from Canada and from Sandy
Hook school will be the first to come
they will come to play with you so you
won't be alone we welcome the Marquez
Green family of Sandy Hook Connecticut
you will fly to La for a King's hockey
game you will meet Stevie Wonder and
he'll dedicate a song to Anna in the
middle of Madison Square Garden
you will also still be required to make
your bed and study hard you can take
comfort in the fact that even on the
days when your parents won't want to get
up they will still get up for you Isaiah
this terrible thing will happen but you
will be so much more than a San Diego
shooting Survivor
your parents will let you be a kid but
insist you be a kid with Big Dreams
[Music]
Dill love music and play hot
you will find your own voice even
speaking alongside Bernice King and
earning a spot at one of the most
prestigious sporting schools in the
country
while there you'll become a student
leader in a role earned by only 12
students in the senior class
you'll become fluent in Spanish
when you're older you're going to want
to practice law to help kids and
families just like yours
the Sandy Hook school shooting will
change your life
you will go from a loved Big Brother
with a 24 7 sidekick to an only child in
under 10 minutes and I won't lie it will
leave you lonely and it won't ever stop
hurting however you will prevail
imagining who she would be if she were
still here will keep her alive in your
heart
[Music]
because you knew her better than anyone
else did that's what will help you in
your toughest moments one remember the
time Anna sang along as you played Come
Thou Almighty King on the piano
you sat next to you on that bench and
you played like you had all the time in
the world
Isaiah pulled strongly to these memories
as they will soon become some of the
only memories you'll have of your sister
as you grow up and deal with your loss
one of the biggest struggles you'll have
is telling others about it
in fact sometimes you'll choose to tell
new people that you're an only child
when they ask
you'll still think about Anna all the
time but any words you have to say about
her will be unable to come out of your
mouth
don't feel bad about that
one day you'll begin to realize that a
way you can keep her alive is through
your words about her
the words will come
you will learn that by keeping her alive
you are calling attention to all those
who have senselessly lost their lives to
gun violence and the inaction of our
nation's leaders
one day you will no longer be eight
you'll have a life to sort out you'll
have to decide what kind of person you
want to be despite the pain you carry
you will also have to use wisdom in
choosing The Company You Keep but
throughout your young life you will have
the blessing of good friends friends who
will be there for you and the tough
times
as an 18 year old you still won't know
where life is going to take you
but you should always remember that you
have a community your friends your
family your God and your sister still
sitting next to you on the piano bench
one day you'll sit where I am waiting to
hear from colleges you will be a Sandy
Hook Survivor but you will also be a
regular kid
you will be more than ready to start
your adult life and meet new friends you
will tell them when it's right about the
sister who sang along when you play the
piano
[Music]
oh man that was powerful what a gift
that he has given us I'm you know I've
gotten to know this family very well and
he has turned out to be such an amazing
young man number one the way he wrote
about his sister she loved sharks Lego
and God and what he said about his
parents too Jimmy and Melba that they
will get up even when they don't even
when they don't want to it's so wise
yeah and the honesty about the pain of
what he's been through and when he meets
new people not always saying he has yeah
I never thought about that before Tony
because it opens things up yeah and him
saying he'll decide when he wants to let
people in and he just wrote something
very beautiful to do so and I want to
repeat that because it was powerful he
said you will take comfort in knowing
that even when your parents don't want
to get up they will get up for you I
wrote that too that is heavy he said I'm
a Sandy Hook Survivor but my life is so
much more than that thank you for that
Isaiah please note to self do it every
time every time thank you